dream
[Applause]
[Music]
dream
welcome to the future of Robotics let
them help you chores around the house
there isn't anything
they can
Doo the next marvelous advancement in
robotics is artificial intelligence by
studying the human brain we have given
independent thought and Life to robots
allowing them to join the American
Workforce almost like real
people now a new technology is Bridging
the Gap between humans and AI making us
closer than than ever by scanning your
own facial features we can give them to
a fully robotic body making them more
human than human with a simulant the
Futures never looked
[Music]
better AI is integrated into all parts
of our day-to-day life they cook our
meals they drive our cars they are our
civil servants keeping the peace and
with the new state ofth Arc defense
system they
[Music]
even
10 years ago today a nuclear warhead was
detonated in Los
Angeles nearly a million people
incinerated in the blink of an eye by
the artificial intelligence created to
protect us we ban and AI in the Western
World so this will never happen
again yet the republics of New Asia do
not share our concern and continue to
develop AI embracing them as equals and
make no mistake we're not at war with
the people of New Asia but the AI they
Harbor this is a fight for our very
existence for as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting
[Applause]
them
noad this is Bravo
inbound
[Music]
that company moving in this is Nomad
copy that sending the right coordinates
baby
girl well they're either going to be
really smart or take off to their
dad she mad at you that was that was a
kick of agreement that was a kick of
agreement that was yeah she's like n n
don't call Daddy that don't say that to
Daddy wait I mean you are 100% sure I'm
the dad
[Music]
right try to understand when it's born
if it starts acting like a complete dick
you can feel pretty confident oh man no
that is you know what I'm good I think
I'm leaving no no I don't want no I just
I feel hurt now I feel insecure and I
don't know if I can carry on this
relationship
I love
[Music]
you
good do okay what's going
on we found an
American
who told you our
location oh please brother they found us
we weren't kful
enough
oh [__] nomad's coming this way let's go
let's go get the boats
hurry Americans are coming American
I Joshua oh
please
why he's seen us we can take him with us
hostage please get your
things please oh do
it what the hell are you doing here
you're going to blow my cover you were
going to give me more time
orders kill n man n man's not here you
hear me n man's not here
the
enemy this is Sergeant Taylor call off
the raid damn it no man's not
here listen I'm under cover you got to
call off the
raid
told me you were out you
promis trust me they don't want you they
just want her
M so let's go let's go come
on
Maya
easy I love
you I would have to do anything to hurt
you
no yo all I
have please we have to go what about the
others what do you
mean they're my family they're not
people
Maya they're not real this is real you
and I are real this love is real that
child is
real
no
this this isn't real I don't mean that
please Sergeant Taylor may
please
[Music]
fire
no
[Music]
man the Creator now available